Auf offener Strasse
wurde gestern Nacht in Zürich
ein 70-jähriger Rabbiner erschossen.
Der Täter konnte flüchten.
Ich hörte einen Knall,
dann hörte ich einen zweiten.
Dann stieg ich aus dem Bett
und öffnete den Storen.
Dann sah ich jemanden wegspringen.
Dann gingen wir raus, um zu schauen.
Dort vorne waren drei Gäste von uns,
die vorher im Restaurant waren,
die waren bereits bei ihm,
er lag schon am Boden.
Der Rabbiner war zu Gast aus Israel.
Täter und Motiv: unbekannt.
Das Opfer: Abraham Grünbaum.
Dass jemand gezielt mit einer
Schusswaffe niedergestreckt wird
am Abend auf der Strasse in Zürich,
das ist schon eher aussergewöhnlich.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Hier hat er geschlafen,
so sieht es aus.
Voilà.
Esra Berkovics -
bei seiner Familie in Zürich
hat Abraham Grünbaum übernachtet.
Seit bald 30 Jahren
war er immer wieder hier zu Gast.
Er ist ein angenehmer Gast gewesen,
eher die stille Seite.
Man musste ihn etwas kitzeln,
damit er etwas erzählt.
Er hat wenig erzählt, über sich hat
er praktisch nie, nicht viel gesagt.
Das ist Rabbi Abraham Grünbaum.
Wie alt ist er denn dort etwa,
Rabbiner Grünbaum?
Da auf dem Bild?
- Mhm.
Etwa 70, als es passiert ist,
ungefähr so.
Er war ein ernster Mann.
Man konnte ihn schon
zum Lächeln bringen,
aber man musste sich
etwas anstrengen.
Aber er hatte
einen sehr schönen Schmeichel.
Meistens sei er in religiöse Bücher
vertieft gewesen, sagt Berkovics,
über sich habe er kaum gesprochen.
In diesem Vorort von Tel Aviv
lebte Abraham Grünbaum.
Nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
hatte er sich hier niedergelassen.
Geboren wurde er in Polen 1930.
Seine Eltern
und fast alle Geschwister
wurden im Zweiten Weltkrieg ermordet.
In Israel heiratete er später.
Hier gründete er eine Talmud-Schule.
Orthodoxe Juden studieren dort
täglich die jüdischen Schriften,
teilweise finanziert vom Staat,
hauptsächlich von Spendern.
Er reiste deshalb
regelmässig nach Europa.
Oft wird in Synagogen für soziale
oder religiöse Projekte gesammelt.
Diese Zürcher Synagoge
war seine letzte Station.
Es ist gegen 22 Uhr, als Abraham
Grünbaum die Synagoge verlässt.
Er ist verabredet
mit seinem Gastgeber Berkovics,
zusammen wollen sie zum Abendgebet.
Grünbaum geht
dem Sihl-Ufer entlang ...
... biegt in die Weberstrasse ein.
* Zwei Knalle *
Die Kugeln treffen Grünbaum.
Der Täter flüchtet.
Abraham Grünbaum,
erschossen am 7. Juni 2001.
Er wird 70 Jahre alt, hinterlässt
eine Familie mit elf Kindern.
Es war ein Tatort
eines Kapitalverbrechens.
Hier irgendwo
lag das Opfer auf der Strasse.
Viele Polizisten,
Staatanwaltschaft etc.,
alles, was bei einem solchen Fall
eben so ausrückt.
Rolf Halonbrenner
arbeitete als Chemiker
beim Wissenschaftlichen Dienst
der Stadtpolizei Zürich.
Kurz vor der Tat
wurde er pensioniert.
Selbst jüdisch-orthodox
kannte er Grünbaum aus der Synagoge.
Ich habe einen Anruf bekommen
von der Chevra Kadisha.
Das ist eine Gruppe von Leuten
aus einer jüdischen Gemeinde,
die sich bei einem Todesfall
um alles kümmern.
Der Anrufer hat gewusst, dass ich
bei der Polizei gearbeitet hatte,
und wollte eigentlich, dass ich
kommen sollte, um zu vermitteln.
Als orthodoxer Jude
und Ex-Mitarbeiter
erklärte er den Behörden
die religiösen Bedürfnisse:
keine Obduktion,
möglichst rasch bestatten.
Er sei auf Verständnis gestossen,
sagt Halonbrenner.
So wurde der Leichnam bald überführt.
In Israel
nimmt die Gemeinde Abschied.
An der Schule, wo Grünbaum
einst selbst studiert hat,
gedenkt man ihm, dem Rabbiner,
der den Holocaust überlebt hatte
und in der Schweiz getötet wurde.
In Zürich läuft
die Suche nach dem Täter.
Ich habe gedacht:
"Das gibt einen heiklen Fall
für die Polizei."
Man hat ...
... sehr wenige Anhaltspunkte,
wo man ansetzen kann,
seien das geschäftliche Beziehungen,
Frauenbeziehungen,
wenn ich das einmal so sagen darf.
Geld oder Beziehungen:
das sind üblicherweise
die ersten Ermittlungsansätze.
Beides wird als mögliches Motiv
hier rasch ausgeschlossen.
Die Suchaktion der Polizei
gilt der Tatwaffe.
Gefunden werden zwei Patronenhülsen,
nicht aber die Pistole.
Sie bleibt unauffindbar.
Die Polizei stellt bald fest:
Grünbaum war nicht beraubt worden.
Bargeld und Flugtickets wurden
bei der Leiche sichergestellt.
Direkte Zeugen werden keine gefunden,
ein Hinweis ergibt sich aber:
Aufnahmen einer Überwachungskamera
aus einem nahegelegenen Hof.
Eine schemenhafte Gestalt scheint
einen Fluchtweg zu suchen
und macht wieder kehrt.
Kaum erkennbar,
aber immerhin eine Spur.
Die Schwierigkeit
in diesem Fall ist,
herauszufinden, welche Motivation
hinter dieser Tat steht.
Was war der Grund dafür,
dass der Rabbiner auf offener
Strasse am Abend erschossen wurde.
Das ist extrem schwierig,
weil man sehr wenig über die Person
wusste, die umgekommen war.
Ein schlimmer Verdacht
drängt sich auf: Judenhass.
Das verunsichert auch
die jüdischen Gemeinden, wie hier,
wo man Grünbaum
an jenem Abend erwartete.
Wir haben abgemacht miteinander,
uns hier um 22.15 Uhr zu treffen,
das war im Juni,
denn das Abendgebet findet den
ganzen Sommer um 22.15 Uhr statt.
Und dann ist er eben ...
Das ist, denke ich,
kurz vor 22 Uhr passiert.
Was ist auf dem Weg hierher
geschehen?
Also, wieso er dort gewesen ist ...
- Das bleibt ein Rätsel.
Und den Weg
von der Freigutstrasse hierher
hat er während 29 Jahren gemacht,
also er hat sich nicht verirrt.
Vielleicht wurde er
von jemandem dorthin getrieben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was macht er dort?
Von der Synagoge
in der Freigutstrasse
brach Abraham Grünbaum damals auf.
Sein Ziel:
die Synagoge an der Erikastrasse -
ein Fussweg von einer Viertelstunde.
Doch nach der Brücke über die Sihl
bog er rechts ab
und gelangte in die Weberstrasse.
Eine brutale Exekution.
Ein Einbruch einer Brutalität,
die wir zum Glück, muss man sagen,
so in der Schweiz
sonst nicht kennen.
Es gibt zwar viele
Schusswaffentötungen in der Schweiz
oder einen grossen Anteil
an Schusswaffentötungen.
Aber diese sind verteilt
auf alle Tötungsdelikte -
auch im familiären Raum
oder in Auseinandersetzungen.
Dass jemand auf offener Strasse
erschossen wird, ist eher selten.
Das kommt vielleicht
bei Streitigkeiten vor Klubs vor
oder im kriminellen Milieu.
Aber dass jemand
gezielt niedergestreckt wird
mit einer Schusswaffe
am Abend auf der Strasse in Zürich,
ist eher aussergewöhnlich.
Doch was war das Motiv?
Wurde ihr Gast getötet,
weil er als Jude erkennbar war?
Nach Ausschluss
anderer möglicher Motive
wie Raub oder eines Beziehungsdelikts
bleibt der Verdacht Antisemitismus.
Es wäre aber ein Attentat
ohne Bekennerschreiben.
Das spricht nicht unbedingt
gegen eine terroristische These,
weil das Nicht-Kommunizieren einer
Tat auch eine Kommunikation ist.
Es wird Unsicherheit
und Angst geschaffen
gerade durch das Fehlen
eines Bekennerschreibens,
das signalisieren würde,
wer der Täter ist.
Und das kann auch das terroristische
Kalkül sogar noch verstärken.
36 Std. nach der Tat:
Ein Verdächtiger wird verhaftet.
Spekulationen
über sein Motiv beginnen.
Doch dann die Meldung seiner
Freilassung - er hat ein Alibi.
Doch ein Attentat?
Der politische Kontext damals
würde dafür sprechen.
Im Sommer 2001 sind wir
mitten in der zweiten Intifada,
die im Jahr zuvor im Nahen Osten
losgegangen ist.
Also wir sind in einer Phase,
in der die Gewalt zwischen
Israel und den Palästinensern
einen neuen Höhepunkt erreicht.
Insofern ist
vor diesem Hintergrund denkbar,
dass diese Gewalt
aus dem Nahen Osten
in die Schweiz übergeschwappt ist
und hier zu diesem
brutalen Mord geführt hat.
Die Tötung in der Weberstrasse:
Grünbaum das Opfer
eines Israel-feindlichen,
antisemitischen Extremisten?
Es wäre ein Muster,
das auch bei anderen Angriffen
in Europa zu beobachten war.
Beweise werden im Fall Grünbaum
jedoch keine gefunden.
So vergehen nach der Tat
mitten in Zürich zehn Jahre,
bis Meldungen aus Deutschland
eine neue Spur vermuten lassen.
Eine "rechtsextreme Terrorzelle",
zum allerersten Mal gebrauchen
deutsche Politiker diesen Ausdruck.
Es geht um die drei
oder auch vier Neonazis
der Gruppe Nationalsozialistischer
Untergrund NSU.
Sie haben in den letzten Jahren
zehn Personen getötet.
In den Ruinen dieser Wohnung
in Deutschland
findet die Polizei
im November 2011 Beweismaterial
für eine Mord- und Raubserie,
die 13 Jahre angedauert hatte,
also seit 1998.
Das wirft Fragen auf.
Die Polizei prüft nun,
ob der sog. NSU
auch Abraham Grünbaum
getötet haben könnte.
Doch auch diese Spur endet
in einer Sackgasse - wieder nichts.
Die meisten Tötungsdelikte
werden eigentlich innerhalb weniger
Tage aufgeklärt in dem Sinn,
dass man innerhalb weniger Tage
einen Tatverdächtigen findet.
Wenn sie jahrelang ermitteln
und keinen Tatverdächtigen finden,
dann wird es schwierig,
nach Jahren noch jemanden zu finden.
Im Zweiten Weltkrieg
musste Grünbaum als Kind
von Polen nach Russland flüchten,
wurde dort interniert.
Später schlug er sich
nach Israel durch.
Über seine Vergangenheit sprach er
kaum - ein ernster Gelehrter.
Ein Mord aus Judenhass -
es bleibt ein Verdacht.
Doch die Bedrohung ist real.
(Rolf Halonbrenner) Die Synagoge,
die wir vorher besucht haben,
wurde 1960 eröffnet
und hatte eine offene Tür.
Jeder konnte ein- und ausgehen.
Heute hat es,
wie Sie gesehen haben, ein Schloss.
Das mussten wir schon vor
etwa 30 Jahren anbringen lassen,
weil leider eine Gefährdung besteht.
Wir müssen damit leben.
Je nach politischer Lage
werden wir hier miteinbezogen,
auch wenn das eine mit dem anderen
überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Was bedeutet miteinbezogen?
Ja, dass man das
in der Umgebung spürt.
Man hat sich gut, sicher gefühlt.
Und man fühlt sich
auch heute sicher.
Aber man liest ein bisschen viel.
Wir sind jetzt gerade in einer Zeit,
in der Antisemitismus
etwas am Ansteigen ist.
Wir hoffen, dass sich das
wieder einmal etwas beruhigt.
Die letzten Meter seines Lebens
führten Rabbiner Abraham Grünbaum
hier der Sihl entlang.
Wer hat auf ihn geschossen?
Und weshalb?
Diese Fragen bleiben offen -
bis heute.
Das Strafverfahren
der Staatsanwaltschaft ist sistiert.
"Cold Cases Schweiz" -
alle Folgen jetzt auf Play SRF.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Nina Oeggerli -2024